I'm curious for you guys from a
performance perspective is it harder to
do something really broad and grand like
imagining a monster or nail something
really mundane and small like sneezing
or muttering to yourself oh I can fully
answer it's easier to sneeze and mutter
to yourself
Oh sneeze and mutter almost everybody
the old sneeze amount of sneezing the
modern that's gonna be our new thing
like like compared to like walking with
the monster this is it
or yeah the big the big sort of
reactions right - I always found that
you know it's like easy but it's hard
yes especially like when it's like three
two one go it's kind of like oh you know
I have to like run around the set and
get myself hyped up before I can't even
your own world when you're just reacting
- yeah and then like when they're like
oh don't do that it's like oh what did i
do though you don't forget like did I do
something you know because I feel like
for me laughing in a scene is like
uncomfortable for me yeah yeah I don't
know how to do it like I'm usually
either crying or screaming so I mean
yeah it's true though like laughing in a
scene I'm always like oh god joy is just
happiness huh one is a one is exhausting
physically the other exhausting mentally
so it's just about whichever one you
could do with longer right well when it
comes to what you guys were given on set
obviously when we see this film we have
all the effects and they have these
beautiful personalities - the monsters
what did you have were there any
practical elements to react - for sure
there was there's a lot of practical
things you know we had a real wind and
rain a hundred miles per hour fans and
but we have a we have a previz you know
a pre visual of what exactly we're gonna
do it kind of looks like an old
PlayStation game you know it's not
really rendered and like colored the
right way and so you you base a lot of
your actions off that but it's up to you
in the moment on the day
to make it real yes but Mike Garrity the
director he wanted a lot of like as much
practical effects and scenery there as
possible so yes you're gonna be looking
at a laser pointer or a tennis ball or
something but he want he get hit sound
effects like monster roars rain snow
sets all that kind of stuff so yeah
there was there's a lot to work with
awesome and everybody here was real yeah
we don't know about the future of the
industry no no no don't take it for
granted so as people who have inhabited
the characters of people who are
surviving a monster invasion
what are your monster survival tips and
who out of the cast do you think would
have the best shot
by far me or Milly I must say Nellie for
the political choice you know because
like she's leading us throughout this
entire film so you know as a soldier I
just take orders from top of the food
chain
I mean I survive I make it out so just
follow Molina I tried you know I mean oh
it's difficult my ID you think yes
I think I I think there amigo would
would survive okay I knew Thank You
Allah give the monsters sure would
either friend them yes or like find a
real cool bunker that's just like I just
got a studio and it's like it's got the
best food like hey you know I don't know
I think you would and I think beer upon
me go would be like one with like the US
oh nice yeah yeah all right thank you so
much Hayley thank you